all right the right wing and republicans
are pretending
that the leak of the supreme court
decision on abortion which we discussed
yesterday
is worse than the trump riot coup
insurrection of january 6 2021.
we knew they were going to do this and
they are axios uh with a very
interesting um uh three-page document
they obtained the three-page memo
about the messaging that republicans
want
on this uh issue and their focus is
the leak is terrible
the leak is a crime although they can't
tell us what law was broken and it's an
absolute travesty
not that abortion rights are now going
to be able to be
brutally curtailed but that we learned
about this decision a few weeks early
and you can check out this document
axios linking to it um and they are uh
focusing in
on this issue of the leak is really the
problem and we have a bunch of uh
examples of this which i'm going to play
for you now
again the real issue here is activist
judges the right loves to say oh
democrats put up activist judges who
will legislate from the bench
all of trump's picks paid lip service
during their confirmation hearings to
the supreme court to i respect president
president's important and roe v wade is
the is precedent right now and then as
far as we know from the draft document
they're all voting to overturn precedent
that's activist judicial uh that is
judicial activism uh without a doubt but
republicans want to focus on oh the leak
the leak the leak we'll look at some
clips ted cruz never
finds a cynical opportunity to uh make
news when he sees it he seizes those
opportunities here he is saying this was
probably some left-wing law clerk this
is a travesty draft opinion that was
leaked last night
i have to say it is utterly stunning
that
anyone at the court would leak a draft
opinion uh in overture this is ted cruz
by the way he has this whole
sincere concern
uh
uh
sort of posture down pat one hand in the
pocket
the other hand kind of signaling and
using this kind of fake sincere voice
100 years of our nation's history this
has never happened
and
now it's not true it's never happened it
actually happened with the roe v wade
decision in the 70s but who's going to
let the facts get in the way of a good
story i am appalled right this is the
most egregious breach of trust
at the supreme court that has ever
happened ever presumably some left-wing
law clerk
angry at the direction the court is
going decided to betray his or her
obligation the trust
that clerk owed to his or her justice
and to the court the word presumably
doing some pretty heavy lifting there no
information about who leaked this so far
then ted cruz continued the rounds and
went on fox news where he said he wants
the person who leaked this serving real
jail time reason it was leaked
is some left-wing presumably law clerk
presumably wanted to put political
pressure on the five justices that
presumably are in the majority right now
they wanted to put heat and they wanted
to invoke politics to try to get them to
change their vote and and by the way if
if that left-wing law clerk succeeds it
will be the most grotesque
politicization of the supreme court in
the history of our nation you mentioned
an fbi investigation i hope there is a
serious one and i hope whoever is
responsible for this not only is fired
instantly but is prosecuted and serves
real jail time for violating the
confidences of the supreme court now
still unable to articulate an actual
crime that was committed then we go to
the daily wire host michael knowles
whose program i've appeared on he says
this he just straight up says this is
worse than the trump riots
absolutely
earth-shattering stuff and i won't let
the libs get me down they're trying to
gum this up they're trying to pressure
the conservatives to switch
what the conservatives need to do right
now
just come out with the opinion
i don't know if it's in its final draft
this goes all the way back to february
so presumably it's in much better shape
come out with the opinion
if the opinion is substantially
different
from this draft
then we will know that the libs
have succeeded
at pressuring at threatening violence
that's really what this is about right
you you whip up all of the riots you're
gonna have a whole lot of mostly
peaceful demonstrations coming out with
molotov cocktails and rocks and all the
rest of it
and it will make a mockery of our system
of government i never want to hear about
the the norms
our norms are sacred cherished
democratic norms i don't want to hear it
from the left anymore i never want to
hear the stupid phrase january 6th this
is
so much more egregious an attack on our
democracy than january 6th ever was it's
not even comparable yeah a decision
leaking a few weeks early is worse than
the trump riots with 700 plus alleged
criminals then we go over to judge
jeanine she also wants jail time doesn't
know what the crime is but jail time she
wants quickly they were on opposite
sides so whoever leaked this we have to
find out who the person is and and and
charge them with a crime i don't know
what the crime would be whether it's
some kind of fraud on government
property i've heard there's a statute
fraud on a government that's very broad
that could include this kind of yeah
that's not gonna work janine sorry
leaking a decision a few weeks early you
could get fired you're definitely not
doing what you're supposed to be doing
in your job at the supreme court i don't
doubt that but this is an issue for the
supreme court as an employer to figure
out fraud on government property give me
a break uh greg gutfeld who's i guess a
comedian he took a different approach
where he had what i guess counts as
comedy as a response to this republican
presidents and republican senators and
you nominate conservative judges then
you will get to overturn roe v wade so
now both sides are going to have to deal
with the fallout on it yeah you know
joey i think you know what scares me
about this decision it's obviously going
to target the truly marginalized and i
speak of pregnant men
um what are your thoughts see how funny
that is guys that's comedy the right is
getting better at comedy and it's really
scaring us on the left and then lastly
right wing kind of uh i don't even know
if she's an actress right wing person
jillian anderson tweeting leaking a
supreme court opinion is far worse than
anything that happened on january 6th
and of course
it's not uh this is one approach and
then after the break we're going to talk
about
they're not going to stop with just
abortion that's coming up later find me
on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video